[Music]
angus t jones the actor who plays the
kid on two and a half men uh had some
harsh words to say
about his show and everyone's talking
about this in hollywood in a clip that
has gone viral the actor called the show
filth urged people to stop watching it
we'll hear with a response to angus's
concerns is our own
andy richter andy
thank you conan
angus
so you're stuck on a tv show you
personally find beneath you
trust me i know exactly what you're
going through
night after night of being forced to
endure a never-ending parade of filth
thinly disguised as entertainment packed
with jokes that aren't fit to clog a bus
station toilet
yeah i get it and to make things even
more humiliating you're not even the
star of this televised garbage fire
you're just that chubby half man playing
second fiddle to some lanky overpaid
egomaniac with a bottomless reservoir of
neediness
the very sound of his high pitched
shrieking voice fills you with so much
rage
takes every ounce of restraint not to
slap that ridiculous fright wig off his
head
well angus
here's my advice to you
do what i do
smile nod politely and
trudge onward through the filth
and as for those nagging little things
you call feelings and a personal belief
system
well there's a place for those and that
place is hidden deep down inside
yourself where no one not you or your
family or even the shrink you've been
lying to for years will ever find
you wouldn't believe how many feelings
you can fit down there if you shove
really hard
thank thank you andy those were
those were inspiring words appreciate it
let's uh no problem buddy
let's just
let's move on with the show shall we
andy oh all right well coming up later
in the show an all-new episode of fart
police
[Music]
good job andy good job
thanks conan